Welcome back to Drew's News.
Next up, American icon William Shatner is about to boldly go
where no 90 year old man has gone before.
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
I don't think that has anything to do with "Star Trek."
That's just my weird like line reading.
No wonder I didn't get those jobs.
People reports, tomorrow Captain Kirk
is actually going into space.
For reals.
Shatner will be launched into the stratosphere
on Jeff Bezos's Blue Origin rocket
that looks so much like something else.
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
Oh my God.
Come on.
Does nobody think that looking at this?
Am I the only one?
Does it have to be that shape?
No.
Now that you mention it, hi.
Sorry.
Suddenly I wanna go into space.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
I'm just saying, I've seen other crafts
that have traveled to space, and they don't look like that.
Anyway, this makes William Shatner
the oldest person to go to space.
Ross, would you wanna go to space?
I would, yeah.
Really?
I would totally wanna go to space.
Hello?
Yeah, I got fricking flyer miles.
I could probably make it.
But I'll tell you,
90 years old and he's gonna orbit the earth.
When I'm 90, I hope I can walk around
a Bed Bath and Beyond.
I mean, think about that.
90 years old and he's still saying yes to adventure.
That is goals.
(audience applauding)
What about you, Ruby?
Would you wanna be shot up in a big rocket to space?
Drew, I would not.
I would not.
I would rather keep my feet on the ground.
Stay on earth.
There's too much of the unknown out there.
I'd get lost, anxious.
No, thanks.
Are you worried you'd get like stuck in space,
like Apollo 13 or something?
'Cause come with me.
I promise you I'd be like MacGayver.
I'd get us home.
I'd fix it.
McGayver?
If you were there...
What, how have I never heard that one before?
I don't know.
I just said it.
Oh my God. MacGayver.
I promise you.
Give me a high heel and a roll of duct tape.
I'm getting that ship home.
(audience cheers)
I'm there. I'm there.
Would you go?
No, I don't think at this point, you know,
maybe when it becomes more commonplace, ubiquitous,
and sort of, you know, standard practice.
Show of hands who would jump on Bezos's rocket.
(Ross laughs)
I'm sorry.
I can't help it.
I'm sorry, you can't look at that rocket and like not...
It's like, everybody's thinking it.
I'm just the person willing to say it out loud.
Yeah, I don't really have...
You know, I heard that there's like actually scuttlebutt
about the Russians are trying to get to space
to make a movie.
Has anyone heard about this?
(audience member claps)
You're clapping your hands.
What do you know?
So yes, they sent up an actress and a producer
yesterday into space to be able to shoot
on the International Space Station,
and actually have a real movie filmed in space.
And it's supposed to be about a surgeon
who goes up to save an astronaut.
Wow.
What is your name?
My name is Sue Siza.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
Well, thank you.
Thank you for the opportunity.
Yeah, I also heard like Tom Cruise
now wants to go make a space movie.
I just, anything with Tom Cruise.
No, I would follow Tom Cruise up in a rocket.
You would?
He is literally my like childhood crush, and he still is.
I know, right? He holds up.
Okay, well you've got the next story, Ruby.
So please take it away.
I do.
So I don't know if you've heard,
but Jennifer Gardner posted this on her Instagram.
She recently texted a selfie of herself
to a complete stranger.
I mean, I don't know about you,
but that's happened to me before.
Not a selfie, but you know, personal information.
You're embarrassed, you know,
and her posting that made me feel a little bit more,
you know, a little better about myself.
That, oh, it's happened to Jennifer Gardner.
I'm okay.
You know, it's happened like five times to me though,
but, what's wrong with me? (laughs)
I sent a video of myself too.
I know this is gonna sound like a name drop.
It's not.
She's my best friend since we were 14 and 16, Cameron Diaz,
and I sent her a video and I happened to be
changing in my closet.
You couldn't see anything.
But then I start like moving the towel around,
and just being like a complete idiot.
And it didn't go to her.
(Ross laughs)
(audience laughs)
It went to a boy named Matthew.
(Ross laughs)
Oh my God.
Who kindly was like, yeah, it's not Cameron.
I think I have her old number
because I've gotten some other stuff for her.
And then I was like, oh God, like, I'm so sorry.
Who are you?
And then I kinda got the sense
that he was still in high school.
(audience laughs)
All right, well, thank you so much.
That's the news, and we'll be right back.
(upbeat bright music)